foreign
[Music]
I'm an artist and I work with lucid
dreams
a lucid dream is a dream in which you're
aware of the fact that you're dreaming
I've had Fairly regular and spontaneous
lucid dreams
since I was a child
I had quite bad nightmares and at some
point I learned to change the course of
the dream to deal with these nightmares
sometimes people say you can control the
dream but it might be more accurate to
say you can influence the dream
as well as Conjuring drawings out of my
lucid dreams I also do portraits of
people I'll meet the dream version of
them in my lucid dream I locate a Dream
pen and a dream piece of paper and I'll
create their portrait in the dream world
and then wake up and recreate that
artwork in Waking Life
it's quite hard to dream about someone
who you don't really know so a lot of
the time it'll be a random person who
contacts me on the internet so what I'll
do is I'll arrange a conversation with
them on Zoom hey hello Brian any
background on me I mean or do you like
to go in with a lot of information or a
little information or what's your
relationship like with your your dreams
so I'll get to know them a little bit
just so it makes it easier to dream of
them
[Music]
I'm planning to meet a specific person
in my in my lucid dream there's a few
different rituals that I'll do to help
increase my chances I might pace around
the room a bit and rehearse the actions
that I'm intending to do in the lucid
dream and another lucid dream I'm gonna
meet Ryan green I'm going to create this
portrait I might meditate for 10 20
minutes before I went to bed I might
place the pen and paper on my desk and
literally just write my goal for that
lucid dream on the paper I'll grab my
pen and I'll put that in my pajama
pocket so when I roll over I might kind
of feel that on my leg it sounds kind of
ridiculous but that will help me
remember what I'm planning to do
drawing in a lucid dream is nothing like
drawing in Waking Life because
everything in a dream is in a constant
state of flux nothing is stable for more
than a couple of seconds until it
transforms into something else although
I'm aware of the fact I'm drawing In The
Dream Most of the content of the drawing
is out of my control it's like an
interaction between my conscious and my
unconscious mind playing itself out on
the page in real time
[Music]
thank you
foreign
started without any visuals I was just
feeling my way around usually the person
would just sort of appear and go Dave
here I am but it didn't happen sounds
weird but I kind of felt I felt
something I was like hang on that's
someone's face and then I told myself
that's going to be Brian Green and then
you kind of
you emerged and from there all the
visuals kicked in that's great that's
great and then from there I held up this
piece of paper
and then some drawings started to appear
on the paper and that's so if I spin it
around
so when I told you it won't necessarily
look like a traditional portrait this
kind of way yeah I would say that it
doesn't quite look like a traditional
Port today I agree with that
characterization so like what am I
looking at to be honest they remain as
mysterious to me as they do too to
anyone most most of the time this is my
favorite one so I I met dream Brian
Green the dream version of you and I
gave you a pen and paper oh you did okay
and you instructed me to draw me or you
instructed me to draw anything just draw
anything okay so that so that's that one
wow that's very cool it's quite funny
actually you started
scribbling but you didn't want to look
at the paper so you were looking away
like that
and you're just drawing like this and
you just scribbled a face and you were
drawing yourself Portrait by the way so
yeah yeah it has a very psychedelic feel
to it it's funny doing this for you
because sometimes people are like they
have a way more sort of outlandish view
of what lucid dreaming is than I do so
they sort of relate to it like a psychic
or something and I'm like I'm one of the
few artists that sometimes I'm begging
people to like read listen to my artwork
I find it fascinating to see how various
influences filters through your brain
and emerges in this unusual context of
lucid dreaming but to go beyond that and
to read in some deeper reality into the
drawing that actually comes directly
from me or is telling me something about
my life that would be hard for me to go
that step the reason I like engaging in
lucid dreaming through artwork is
because art is all about asking
questions right it's not about settling
on answers and I think that is the most
healthy way for me to engage with lucid
dreaming I do it in like a playful way
and I just always keep an open mind and
I try to be comfortable with the
ambiguity and the Mystery of Dreams